a mother and son found dead millions of
dollars in missing money and the
downfall of a family Dynasty The Saga of
the Murdoch family attracted national
attention after disbarred South Carolina
lawyer Alec Murdock was accused of
killing his wife and son every day
almost for since the homicides something
new has happened and I think that's just
captivating to people Murdoch was
charged with two counts of murder in
July 2022 after his wife Maggie and Son
Paul were found fatally shot a year
earlier at the family's hunting estate
he's pleaded not guilty to the charges
and will face trial in Colleton County
South Carolina here's what you need to
know about the case against Alec Murdoch
the first stage of the trial is jury
selection but because of the prominent
family name selecting 12 jurors that
aren't familiar with the Murdoch family
or the case will be a challenge jury
selection is just going to be incredibly
tough everybody knows the murdochs
that's because the Legacy and legal
influence of the Murdoch family in
Southeastern South Carolina dates back
to the early 1900s the family
established one of the state's dominant
law firms in 1910 and three generations
of murdochs have presided as solicitors
over the 14th judicial circuit which
covers five counties in South Carolina
from you know 1920 when the first
Murdoch ran for office until you know
2006 they knew every law enforcement
officer in their region the local
agencies that first arrived at the crime
scene recused themselves from the case
because of the family's close ties to
law enforcement they have this pretty
serious reputation even now even with
elect Murdoch in jail for more than a
year people are still intimidated by
this family because because they've
known them their whole life Richard
Ellen Murdoch are you guilty or not
guilty of the felonies wherein you stand
indicted not guilty while investigating
the double homicide law enforcement
discovered evidence of a string of
alleged Financial crimes he was a
personal injury lawyer his clients were
some of the poorest of the poor and the
most badly injured and he's accused of
siphoning money off of of judgments that
he won on behalf of his clients Murdoch
has pleaded not guilty to most of those
charges but in a filing submitted to the
court prosecutors State the alleged
wrongdoing that led to these charges
gave him motive for murder Alec was
under a huge amount of pressure to turn
over to the court evidence of his
finances in a boat crash case involving
his son and prosecutors say that if he
had done that it would have led to the
unraveling of of this alleged scheme of
crime that he'd been running for a
decade and that was enough to set him
off that night and kill his wife and son
prosecute tutor state that after Maggie
and Paul were found dead people
immediately treated defendant as the
victim of an unspeakable tragedy the Day
of Reckoning vanished the defense has
called this Theory illogical and
implausible
the prosecution has a tough climb here
they have got to prove Beyond a
reasonable doubt that ellick alone
committed these murders in a
circumstantial case and in a case where
the evidence is in in some question in
some cases the shirt Murdoch wore on the
night of the murders is expected to be a
key piece of evidence in the trial
according to court documents it had
microscopic amounts of blood spatter
something prosecutors say indicates
Murdoch was close to one of his family
members when they were shot but in a
separate filing defense attorneys
claimed that the state used unreliable
methods to test the shirt ultimately
making it impossible to test further it
could help the prosecution if they're if
their expert is able to say yes there
was this this this High Velocity impact
spatter on this shirt but it opens up a
chance for the defense because they were
never able to have their own expert
independently look at it instead the
prosecution could lean on digital
evidence to help prove their case court
documents filed by the defense describe
a video recorded on Paul's phone saying
he can be heard having a lighthearted
conversation with his mom and dad in the
background which places Murdoch at The
Hunting estate a little over an hour
before he called 9-1-1 which conflicts
with the timing of his Alibi the defense
has said yeah maybe he was imprecise
about you know who he saw and when but
what that video shows is them laughing
and talking with one another so this was
a loving family and you're going to tell
me that after this video was recorded
elik Murdoch shot his wife and kid
that's unacceptable
the trial is expected to last several
weeks and prosecutors are seeking life
imprisonment for Murdoch it's incredible
to think about the family built this
name for a hundred years and the reason
it will be remembered is because of
Ellen and what he's alleged to have done